en el terreno al norte de bahamut las
fuerzas ucranianas siguen resistiendo a
la ofensiva rusa
cerca de las líneas enemigas estas
unidades de artillería tratan de
infligir El mayor daño posible a las
tropas rusas que les hacen frente
Nuestro objetivo es la Infantería a
veces hay vehículos blindados ligeros o
tanques pero la Infantería es el
objetivo principal las tropas rusas que
rodean bajo mundo ocupan una posición
muy expuesta y han sufrido según algunos
analistas cinco veces más bajas que los
ucranianos una de las principales
figuras de la batalla por
bajon jefe del grupo ruso Wagner ha
admitido que el grupo padeció grandes
pérdidas los servicios de inteligencia
ucranianos Y estadounidenses afirman que
Wagner ha tenido 30.000 hombres muertos
capturados o heridos desde febrero de
2022 en un mensaje de audio el viernes
priegoshin anunció que Wagner abriría
centros de reclutamiento en 42 ciudades
rusas
a pesar de la colosal resistencia de las
fuerzas armadas de Ucrania seguimos
adelante a pesar de los palos que nos
ponen en las ruedas a cada paso lo
superaremos juntos
la caída de bahamut que las tropas rusas
han descrito como cerca en numerosas
ocasiones sigue retratándose estas fotos
de satélite muestran la magnitud de los
combates en los que cada metro de
terreno se gana un enorme costo humano
la ciudad en la que vivían 70.000
personas está ahora casi totalmente en
ruinas